A superhero role shot out of the sky. A
token tough guy this network paid to protect.
These are just a few stars who made big
bucks for a role they never even played!
It's no secret that movie stars get paid
an obscene amount of money for their work.
Between upfront deals, on-set perks, and box
office percentages, it's not uncommon for prolific
actors to earn millions of dollars per film. It’s
reasonable as long as the actors are doing their
jobs and entertaining the masses. But sometimes
it transpires that an actor will receive a hefty
payday and still not appear in the project they're
getting paid for. Sometimes their scenes simply
end up on the cutting room floor. Sometimes the
film itself doesn't come together. And sometimes
a rival studio might even bribe them to turn
down an offer. Whatever the case may be, here
are some actors who found a way to make money from
roles despite not appearing in the final product.
Over the course of eight years and
six seasons, James Gandolfini was
best known to audiences worldwide as the
lead of HBO's crime drama "The Sopranos."
One of the most acclaimed and
well-regarded TV shows of all time,
the saga of gangsters, their families,
and their therapy bills is often cited as
originating the modern era of peak TV. A central
part of its success was Gandolfini as Tony,
a New Jersey mob boss who balanced a menacing
exterior with a more sensitive inner life.
"Sounds like me alright."
After the show's controversial conclusion,
any other network would have considered
his casting to be a massive coup.
As it turns out, this nearly
happened with NBC and "The Office."
With Steve Carell planning to depart the hit
comedy in its seventh season, the hunt was on
to find a high profile replacement to fill his
shoes. Though James Spader was eventually cast,
apparently Gandolfini was close to nabbing the
role. According to his "Sopranos" co-star Michael
Imperioli, the actor was so close that HBO paid
him $3 million to turn down the role. The reason
given was so that Gandolfini could continue
developing the limited series "The Night Of"
with the network. Tragically, it wouldn't
premiere until three years after his death.
It's speculated that they also wanted to
preserve the tough-guy legacy of Tony Soprano,
and were concerned that a sillier role
in "The Office" might detract from that.
The "Harry Potter" franchise is no stranger to
recent controversies. Between the disappointing
critical and commercial reception of the
most recent film and author J.K. Rowling’s
controversial statements, the last thing these
spin-offs needed was one of its primary cast
members in hot water. Yet that's precisely
what happened with Johnny Depp, who had been
cast as the villainous Gellert Grindelwald
in a surprise cameo at the end of "Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them." He later had his
role significantly fleshed out in the sequel.
Unfortunately for Depp, personal drama
began to overshadow his acting career.
In the wake of a vicious and highly public
court battle with his ex-wife Amber Heard,
the higher-ups at Warner Bros. decided that being
associated with Depp was more trouble than it was
worth. As a result, the role of Grindelwald was
recast with "Hannibal" star Mads Mikkelsen for
the third film. Still, Depp managed to pocket his
full $16 million salary per his original contract.
"Contain your emotions."
With a body of work ranging from classy
Oscar fare to schlocky action thrillers and
everything in between, Nicolas Cage's career is
the stuff of legend. Yet one of the actor's most
infamous roles was one he never got the chance to
play. This of course was the title character of
the equally legendary "Superman Lives." It was a
superhero blockbuster that would have been helmed
by Tim Burton with a script by Kevin Smith. It
seemed like a match made in comic book heaven.
However, the film was not to be. Though
an official reason was never given,
many have speculated that it may have to
do with the disastrous reception of Joel
Schumacher's "Batman & Robin." This film
could have made parent company Warner Bros.
apprehensive about jumping into another
big-budget movie about tights and capes.
Jonathan Gems theorized that the studio was
somehow punishing the filmmaker for that film's
lackluster performance. The entire affair
was eventually chronicled in the documentary
"The Death of Superman Lives: What Happened?" And
though Cage never got the chance to play Kal-El,
he did reportedly collect a cool
$20 million for his trouble.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.